donc Madame Messieurs chers collègues
donc nous poursuivons nos travaux dans
le cadre de la préparation de notre
étude sur le foncier agricole outremer
dont j'ai l'honneur d'être le rapporteur
avec mon collègue tanni Mohamed so Ali
qui nous rejoindra dans un instant mais
bon aujourd'hui c'est un peu compliqué
il y a encore un texte de loi dont il
doit je crois intervenir donc dès qu'il
peut y nous rejoindre je souhaite
d'abord
la bienvenue à nos invités et je vous
remercie de votre présence et avant de
vous présenter madame et messieurs je
salue le président
Stéphane nathano qui nous suit en
visioconférence depuis Saint-Pierre et
Miquelon et qui vous souhaite vous
adresser un petit mot de bienvenue
monsieur le Président c'est à toi
merci cher chervivet j'espère que vous
m'entendez bien très heureux de vous
retrouver je remercie évidemment nos
invités à mon tour et en particulier
Arnaud martranchard que nous entendons
pour la seconde fois mais le sujet cher
Arnaud le mérite je vous livre quelques
remarques avant de pouvoir de donner la
parole
cheryvette pour que tu puisses mener
cette audition l'étude sur le foncier
disponible lancée début mars touche
quasiment à sa fin puisque l'examen du
rapport est fixé par notre délégation au
28 juin prochain donc il était heureux
que les représentants des services
ministériels dont il a beaucoup été
question puisse répondre aux
interrogations évidemment de nos
rapporteurs sur ce sujet qui reste
complexe comme vous avez pu le constater
au travers du questionnaire de nos
rapporteurs leurs interrogations nos
interrogations sont nombreuses et
couvrent beaucoup de sujets qui ont
entrés à la réglementation et à son
application effective le temps va nous
manquer évidemment pour aborder
l'ensemble des territoires ultramarins
et la moisson sur les dromes et déjà
fort riche si vous me permettez ces
suppressions spéciales
pour clore notre tour d'horizon je vous
indique que nous entendrons aussi
prochainement en l'occurrence le 20 juin
le ministre de l'Agriculture mais de la
souveraineté alimentaire monsieur
marcéno et donc argent également que ce
sujet sensible
sur ce sujet sensible et ministères
concernés travaillent de cancer dans le
contexte que vous connaissez qui est
celui du prochain somme qui visiblement
est annoncé désormais le 3 juillet
prochain il se tiendra en juillet juste
après la sortie de notre rapport et nous
espérons que les recommandations ne
rapporteur ou une partie au moins est
figurant d'ailleurs le ministre caraco à
l'intention de réunir à nouveau les deux
délégations de l'assemblée du Sénat pour
faire un point sur sur ces travaux du
cium au cours des auditions je relève
qu'il a beaucoup été question de conflit
d'usage comme dans les agones d'ailleurs
l'urbanisation qui s'étend mais il y a
aussi un renforcement de la défense des
espaces boisés naturels sur les
territoires qui sont qui sont exigus
évidemment à part la Guyane
naturellement les terres agricoles se
retrouvent prise en quelque sorte en
tenaille entre les deux leur protection
est actuellement un véritable combat à
mener des critiques comportées aussi sur
le manque de coordination des services
de l'État et le dialogue insuffisant
avec les autres acteurs sur les
territoires
on reçoit vraiment ce besoin de
coordination de concertation de dialogue
fait souhaiter d'ailleurs une sorte de
guichet unique dans chaque territoire et
peut-être davantage de simplification
dans des procédures notamment pour ne
pas décourager les jeunes agriculteurs à
venir s'installer et favoriser le retour
dans nos territoires nous sommes
également en attente de vos éclairages
vous en doutez sur le bilan des cdp9 et
le rôle des affaires dans les outre-mer
faut-il les réformer si oui sur quel
point précisément selon vous il faudrait
pouvoir les réformer et enfin nous
fondons beaucoup d'espoir aussi sur le
prochain pacte et projet de loi
d'orientation et d'avenir
il nous faudra pas évidemment oublier
les outre-mer dans les concertations à
mener et les dispositions à inscrire
qu'il y a une situation d'urgence pour
l'avenir de l'agriculture dans nos
territoires de manière de manière
générale merci donc à nos rapporteurs et
à nos invités pour nos éclairages et je
vous souhaite évidemment de bons travaux
que je suis vrai avec beaucoup d'intérêt
connecté à distance à quelques-uns j'y
vais je te laisse se mettant le soin de
diriger cette audition merci
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
donc mes chers collègues dont nous
recevons ce matin Monsieur Arnaud
martinchard délégué un terme ministériel
de la transformation agricole des
Outre-mer qui représente le ministère
des outre-mer et celui de l'agriculture
et de la souveraineté alimentaire c'est
la seconde fois que nous avons le
plaisir de vous accueillir puisque vous
étiez venu le 6 avril avec le directeur
de l'office de développement de
l'économie agricole d'outre-mer Monsieur
Jacques Andrieu vous êtes cette fois-ci
doublement mandatée par les ministères
que j'ai cités et nous sommes heureux
que vous puissiez nous apporter de
nouveaux éclairages à ce stade de notre
réflexion nous entendrons ensuite
monsieur Christophe sugel adjoint au
sous-directeur de la sous-direction de
l'aménagement durable direction de
l'habitat de l'urbanisme et des paysages
du ministère de la transition écologique
nous avons été très frappés lors de
notre déplacement à Martinique par
l'importance croissante de la
problématique de l'eau et de la demande
d'irrigation pour l'agriculture
nous attendons avec intérêt vous
éclairages sur les moyens mobilisables
et les investissements possibles dans
ces territoires confrontés à l'urgence
climatique et enfin nous entendons
monsieur Jean-Yves collet président du
conseil d'administration de l'Office
National des Forêts accompagné de Madame
Nathalie barbe directrice des relations
institutionnelles de l'outre-mer et de
la Corse à chacun de nos rendez-vous ou
presque lors de notre déplacement le
rôle de l'ONF a été évoqué à la fois
comme protecteur des espaces dont il a
la charge mais aussi comme élément
bloquants pour l'extension ou la remise
en culture de certaines terrains à
vocation agricoles donc nous serons très
heureux de vous entendre sur ces
difficultés dans un premier temps vous
allez avoir la parole dans l'ordre que
je viens dénoncer durant une dizaine de
minutes chacun pour vos propos
liminaires une trame d'ailleurs de
questions vous a été adressée vous
pourrez vous en inspirer pour la partie
correspondant à vos missions en tant que
rapporteur avec mon collègue Tani
Mohamed qui je l'espère va pouvoir nous
rejoindre nous pourrons intervenir à
tout moment afin de vous demander des
précisions complémentaires et ensuite je
donnerai la parole à ceux de nos
collègues qu'il a demandéont voilà
Monsieur Martin chat je vous donne tout
de suite la parole
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les sénatrices et les
sénateurs Mesdames et Messieurs les
administrateurs
sur le les alors je sais pas si je
réponds directement aux questions que
vous m'avez
rapidement pareil pour pas le passer
trop de temps puis on pourra bien sûr y
revenir sur le foncier agricole qui est
bien sûr une priorité pour le ministère
de l'Agriculture et des Outre-mer
puisque vous savez que il y a eu une
impulsion politique à très haut niveau
du président de la République qui a
souhaité qu'on avance vers
autant que faire ce peu vers l'autonomie
alimentaire on a eu des comités de
transformation agricole qui se sont
tenus en 2020 en 2021-2022 en 2023 les
ministres de l'Agriculture des Outre-mer
de la santé de la de la mer ont écrit au
préfet pour leur demander de constituer
des plantes souveraineté alimentaires
pour chacun des territoires avec des
objectifs et que ces objectifs en tout
cas pour les plus les plus parlants
c'est à dire les taux de couverture dans
chacun des territoires pour chacune des
grandes filières seront publiées dans
ce qu'on appelle une des politiques
prioritaires du gouvernement
la politique prioritaire du gouvernement
il y en a une qui s'appelle accompagner
le développement des territoires
ultramarins et elles sont divisées en
chantier et un de ces chantiers c'est
déployer les plans de souverainetés
alimentaires dans les territoires donc
les taux de couverture seront publiés
dans un outil un outil public qui
s'appelle pilote et
à partir des données que nous ont
transmis les préfets les plantes
souveraineté on les amenant tous reçus
et ils ont été bâtis avec l'ensemble des
acteurs locaux c'est-à-dire les
principaux
on a bien sûr la collectivité qui gère
le fait Ader qui est très important
d'associer ces travaux locaux mais aussi
les représentants du monde agricole dans
les chambres agricultures que les
syndicats agricoles que les
représentants des grandes filières
et ces plans de souveraineté ont permis
de de fixer donc des objectifs alors sur
les objectifs sur la SAE en tant que tel
qui est la base de la souveraineté
alimentaire on a des statistiques qui
montrent que la SAE diminue alors elle
diminue
on sait que c'est pas une c'est pas
spécifique aux outre-mer elle baisse
partout
dans l'Hexagone sauf sur un territoire
la Guyane qui est le seul territoire de
la France ou la saü augmente donc on
essaye de mettre en place des
dispositifs pour freiner
cette baisse de la SAU et on essaye
aussi d'estimer les besoins alors sur
les besoins
chaque territoire
a fait des trajectoires qui vont sembler
réalistes on sera pas l'autonomie
alimentaire en 2030 c'est pas possible
sur certaines filières comme les
céréales c'est pas réaliste sur les
filières animales on sera pas non plus à
l'autonomie alimentaire et même si on
est si on pourra progresser sur les taux
de couverture on reste dépendant en tout
cas pour les filières port les filières
volailles de d'une alimentation qui
constitue 60 à 80% du coût le coût de la
production en filière animale c'est
l'alimentation et cette alimentation
elle ne vient pas du territoire elle
vient de l'Hexagone donc c'est une
souveraineté un peu particulière et
quand on a voulu estimer les besoins en
surface pour essayer
d'atteindre les objectifs qu'on s'est
fixés on a eu des il y a des données qui
ont été publiées par le Cirad et qui
qu'on trouve sur internet c'est un
rapport de Monsieur
voisin qui fixe des surfaces ça va de
quelques centaines d'hectares à peu près
par territoire sur les fruits et légumes
et des besoins un peu plus importants si
on veut développer la filière bovine
puisqu'il y a des besoins en pâturage
qui peuvent être de plusieurs milliers
d'hectares mais on estime que les
besoins sont
compatibles avec le disponible
on a par exemple je dois me sur le en
Guadeloupe sur une surface de 31 000
hectares la filière végétale aurait des
besoins de 300 hectares la Guyane sur
36000 hectares de SAU aurait besoin de
2500 hectares la Martinique a elle-même
estimé c'est la collectivité
territoriale qui a qui a fait un rapport
qui a produit une délibération et qui a
publié une stratégie développement elle
estime qu'elle a besoin de 1000 hectares
la Réunion on estime qu'il y a besoin de
500 hectares maillot de 140 hectares on
va dire que le disponible
couvre largement
ses besoins
qu'on a des des problèmes d'aménagement
donc il faut travailler sur
l'aménagement et sur la protection sur
la protection donc on sait qu'il y a
différents outils l'outil qui est le
plus sensible c'est les CDP vous savez
que contrairement à l'Hexagone les avis
pour laisser des pena foutre-mer son
conformes et le ministère de
l'Agriculture défend le maintien d'un
avis conforme parce qu'on estime que si
on supprime cet avis conforme on va
aller vers un émiettage du foncier
agricole évidemment les mers ne sont pas
d'accord avec cette avis et préférerait
ils l'ont déjà dit très clairement au
président de la République en février
2019 ils reviennent aussi
il demande aussi cette même demande
auprès de Monsieur Jean-François Carenco
de passer à la vie la vie simple y
compris certains parlementaires
ultramarins en disant ben écoutez il y a
pas de raison de nous déposséder de ce
pouvoir de décision outre-mer et puis on
est aussi on est aussi capable que les
maires de l'Hexagone pour décider de ce
qu'il faut protéger de ce qu'il faut pas
protéger donc laissez-nous faire donc
c'est un sujet c'est un sujet législatif
qui sera débattu au Parlement vous savez
qu'il y a le projet de loi d'orientation
et d'avenir agricole qui va passer au
Parlement cette année donc il y aura il
y aura des des débats à cette occasion
sur le sujet voilà le ministère de la
Culture est plutôt pour les mères va
pour le maintien de la vie conforme les
mets à son plutôt
sur un avis différent il revient au
débat parlementaire de trancher sur
cette sur cette décision
sur les affaires qui sont un autre
instrument
de préservation du foncier alors
d'aménagement ça va faire c'est avant
tout une société d'une société
d'aménagement foncier des espaces ruraux
donc c'est avant tout une prestation
d'aménagement qui est attendue mais
c'est vrai qu'il y a aussi beaucoup un
rôle de protection avec ce fameux droit
de préemption qui permet
aux ça fait qui ont un agrément d'avoir
automatiquement à droite de préemption
donc elles peuvent s'opposer à une vente
de terre agricoles si elles estiment que
on va avoir une perte de capacité
d'exploitation agricole ou si le prix ne
correspond pas au prix du marché
on sait qu'on a une difficulté outre-mer
parce que les affaires qui sont des
sociétés anonymes et bien elle
fonctionne dans l'Hexagone à l'équilibre
financier parce que elle se rémunère sur
le marché du foncier un peu comme des
agences immobilières or
outremer à la situation est différente
le marché du foncier est beaucoup moins
important que dans l'Hexagone et la fn
s'affaire a produit des études qui
montrent que
le modèle de fonctionnement à
l'équilibre de l'Hexagone n'est pas
transposable outre-mer et que des
affaires aujourd'hui ne peuvent pas
aboutir à un équilibre financier
sur le la base du modèle hexagonal donc
aujourd'hui elle bénéficie des affaires
outre-mer d'une dotation il y a une
enveloppe du ministère de l'Agriculture
qui qui est variable un peu tous les
anges je vous donnerai le détail mais
qui est affecté au safer outre-mer et à
la Corse pour les aider à préserver leur
équilibre on a aussi
un Mayotte on n'a pas de sa faire mais
on a un établissement public foncier qui
dispose de l'agrément s'affaire depuis
assez peu de temps d'ailleurs depuis
deux ans et qui met en oeuvre le droit
de préemption et qui donc à ce titre
désormais bénéficie d'une part de la de
l'enveloppe nationale qui est affectée
aux affaires on a la particularité de la
Guyane ou on avait un établissement
public foncier qui dans les textes
pouvaient avoir la la
compétence sur le foncier agricole mais
qui ne l'avait pas dans les faits il
avait dans les textes mais pas dans les
faits parce qu'il manquait un décret que
que le ministère de l'agriculture ne
prenait pas parce qu'il y avait des
débats localement sur le fait qu'il que
l'établissement public foncier ne
pouvait pas suffisamment protéger le
foncier agricole et que donc il y avait
des on souhaitait une affaire au niveau
local et dans les accords de Guyane il
est prévu qu'il y ait une safer donc il
y a eu constitution d'un groupement
d'intérêts publics il y a eu une affaire
qui s'est constituée une association et
maintenant il y a une nouvelle
présidente qui a été élue récemment et
qui est allé voir le le ministre de
l'Agriculture pas plus tard que cette
semaine pour demander à ce que au
démarrage le ministère de l'Agriculture
puisse aider en subventionnant la SAFER
pendant les premières années tout en
proposant que par la suite la SAFER
exerce une prestation d'aménagement
foncier rémunéré qui lui permettrait de
pas dépendre ad vitam eternam les
subventions des subventions publiques
actuellement elle souhaite être
subventionnée pour moitié par l'État et
pour moitié par la collectivité
territoriale de Guyane et donc ce qu'on
lui a dit c'est que on pouvait envisager
un soutien initial au démarrage mais
qu'on avait besoin
de disposer de ce qui est un document
obligatoire dans le cadre de la
procédure d'agrément des affaires qui
est le plan le programme plurianuel
d'activité de la SAFER qu'on n'avait pas
pour le moment afin qu'on puisse savoir
ce qui est prévu de faire avec les
subventions que le ministère pourrait
attribuer alors il y a un autre sujet
qui revient régulièrement sur la table
comment faire pour améliorer le
financement des affaires et un sujet qui
existe depuis plusieurs années ça serait
la taxe spéciale d'équipement vous savez
qu'aujourd'hui la taxe spéciale
d'équipement elle est attribuée aux
établissements publics fonciers qui
s'occupe du foncier
urbain
et que il y a un plafond qui est dans
les textes qui est alors je suis pas si
la changer mais il y a quelques je pense
pas c'était un plafond de 20 euros par
habitant et par an c'est toujours ça
donc il y a certains territoires où ce
plafond n'est pas atteint je pense en
particulier à la Guyane je pense que ce
plafond n'est pas atteint donc il y a
des débats depuis plusieurs années sur
le fait qu'on pourrait augmenter cette
taxe spéciale d'équipement mettons de 2
euros et qu'on affecte très cette taxe
au fonctionnement des affaires alors ça
aussi c'est un sujet qui discutera pas
en projet de loi d'orientation et
d'avenir agricole puisque c'est un sujet
qui doit se discuter en projet de loi de
finance au Parlement avec d'un côté on
voit bien le bénéfice que pourrait en
retirer les affaires
d'avoir une taxe affectée avec deux
inconvénients qui nécessitent un débat
au Parlement un c'est que c'est quand
même une taxe supplémentaire qui va
peser sur le citoyen et de
il n'est pas d'usage d'affecter des
taxes à des sociétés anonymes si elles
sont plutôt affectées à des
établissements en public c'est le cas en
particulier des établissements publics
fonciers mais c'est pas courant et c'est
pas dans la norme d'affecter une taxe à
une société anonyme donc ça ça devrait
discuté on doit de finance
après
on a le problème des terres en friche et
des terrains cultes
on en avait discuté lors de ma dernière
émission vous deviez
auditionner les notaires j'ai vu qu'il y
a vu une audition avec les notaires sur
ce sujet je ne sais pas si
l'objectif initial qui était de discuter
avec eux des modifications législatives
qui pourraient être utiles pour
améliorer la mise en culture des terres
en friche et des terres sous statut
d'indivision a été atteint
c'était ça quand même l'objet de
l'audition concrètement qu'on discute
des quelles étaient les facteurs de
blocage législatif qui freinaient la
mise en culture des terres inculte donc
il faut
il faut suivre les conclusions si au
cours de ces la conclusion de cette
audition vous avez identifié des
facteurs législatifs qui mériteraient
d'être modifiées et sinon chaque
territoire dans le cadre de sa feuille
de route territoriale vers la souverain
complémentaires à identifier le foncier
comme un facteur limitant et donc il
leur est demandé de mettre en oeuvre les
procédures de mise en valeur des
terrains cultes qui existent aujourd'hui
dans le Code rural mais qui sont
peut-être insuffisamment mis en œuvre on
peut aller il y a une procédure on met
en demeure le propriétaire et s'il ne le
fait pas on peut aller jusque à
infirmage obligatoire décidé par le
préfet qui dit puisque vous ne faites
rien et bien moi je mets en faire match
votre terre et c'est une décision mais
qui qui ne va pas jusqu'au bout souvent
donc je pense qu'il faut relancer ce
sujet c'est assez c'est assez important
sinon il y avait des questions sur les
les taux de couverture
dans les territoires quels sont les les
taux de couverture actuelle alors c'est
taux de couverture sont publiques je
peux vous donnerai le lien
ils sont publiés sur un observatoire qui
est l'observatoire de l'office de
développement d'économie agricole
d'outre-mer où on a des taux de
couverture qui sont publiés tous les ans
avec deux taux de couverture selon ce
que vous prenez en compte
on va dire taux de couverture c'est une
fraction le numérateur qui est la
production locale donc ça on peut la
mesurer et puis le dénominateur c'est
les besoins les besoins c'est la somme
de la production locale plus des
importations mais tout dépend de ce que
vous mettez dans les importations vous
pouvez soit mettre uniquement mettons
sur les viandes ou les produits
alimentaires les produits frais ou
congelés ou vous rajoutez en plus les
produits transformés et là évidemment
dans le premier cas vous avez un taux de
couverture qui est plus élevé
puisque vous avez un dénominateur plus
faible que dans le deuxième cas où vous
rajoutez les produits transformés et
donc vous avez un taux qui est moins
qui est plus faible et à ce moment là
c'est vrai que on peut donc voir deux
taux différents mais c'est pas atypique
à l'Outre-mer je rappelle que dans le
plan national de souveraineté fruits et
légumes qui vient d'être publié pour
l'Hexagone pour tout le territoire
national hexagone plus outremer et bien
il y a deux taux de couverture il y a le
taux de couverture produit frais et le
taux de couverture produit frais et
transformé donc on a tous ces taux c'est
public et on s'est fixé des objectifs de
progression de ces différents taux donc
je vous enverrai le lien pour le
distribuer à l'ensemble de la délégation
tout ceci est parfaitement public et
transparent et enfin
on avait le problème des retraites et le
problème de l'eau alors sur les
retraites bien sûr
on a cette difficulté que les retraites
agricoles sont très faibles outre-mer
principalement parce que les
agriculteurs ne disposent ne disposent
pas de carrière complète
et que les progrès qui ont été faits qui
sont de dire que chaque retraite ne peut
pas être inférieure à 75% du SMIC ce
n'est possible que pour les carrières
complètes quelqu'un qui n'a pas cotisé
il aura pas le droit à 75% du SMIC donc
les gens restent et ça empêche les
jeunes de s'installer donc dans le cadre
de la vous savez que sur le projet de
loi d'orientation et d'avenir on a
instauré des concertations dans tout le
territoire national y compris outre-mer
donc on a plein de de demandes qui nous
sont remontées il y avait trois groupes
de travail orientation formation
installation transmission
adaptation au changement climatique et
dans ces demandes revient ce problème
des retraites en disant les jeunes ne
peuvent pas s'installer parce que les
retraites sont trop faibles donc on
demande de payer une préretraite
pour aider les les
agriculteurs en âge de prendre leur
retraite à prendre leur retraite on
demande aussi à ce que il y a une
évolution de la SPA alors l'ASPA c'est
un sujet qui a déjà été débattu au
Parlement y compris au Sénat en
délégation c'est et à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est un sujet qui n'est pas
spécifique d'ailleurs à l'Outre-mer on a
ce même problème de la SPA dans
l'Hexagone avec le problème du
recouvrement les
beaucoup d'agriculteurs hésitent à
demander la SPA parce que ben ils disent
oui mais quand je vais décéder ça sera à
mes ça sera à mes
mais
ayants droits mes enfants de rembourser
disons qu'ils ne veulent pas mettre
cette dette sur le dos de leurs enfants
et donc il demande pas la SPA et qu'on a
toujours ce problème de la maison
d'habitation moi il me semble je l'ai
déjà dit mais je peux le redire qui
semblerait cohérent que la maison
d'habitation dans les outre-mer
soit réputé
attenante au bâtiment d'exploitation
agricoles et donc exclut du champ de
recouvrement de la SPA pourquoi parce
que tout simplement l'histoire a été
différente c'est l'histoire il y a eu
l'histoire des corps de ferme dans
l'Hexagone qui n'existent pas outre-mer
et dans les faits les maisons
d'habitation souvent ne sont pas
attenant au bâtiment d'exploitation
agricole et donc sont incluses dans le
champ recouvrement et ça ça pourrait
être modifié c'est c'est mon avis dans
la loi et ça permettrait à plusieurs
agriculteurs d'avoir un revenu décent la
SPA doit être à plus de 900 euros par
mois et donc aux jeunes de s'installer
et donc d'aller vers la souveraineté
alimentaire c'est un débat qui doit
avoir lieu aussi en loi de finance
sur les besoins en eau alors chaque
plante souveraineté alimentaire comporte
un plan d'action sur le problème de
l'eau agricole
pour
travailler avec le gestionnaire du
réseau qui est chargé de l'entretien et
les investissements nécessaires parce
qu'on a souvent un coup important pour
entretenir le
réseau d'eau non seulement le réseau
d'eau potable chacun connaît la
situation de l'eau potable sera le
territoire ultramarin et en particulier
de la Guadeloupe mais il y a des appuis
publics pour ça on a eu des appuis
publiques au travers du PSN donc ça il
faut le mobiliser mais aussi au travers
du plan de relance et de France 2030
encore maintenant où on a des guichets
pour aider et soutenir les équipements
qui pour faire face aux aléas
climatiques et dans les dans le
changement climatique on a la sécheresse
et donc on a le problème de l'eau
agricole donc il faut mobiliser ces
outils d'investissement et par ailleurs
vous savez que le Président de la
République a annoncé le 30 mars le plan
O pour qu'on travaille sur cette
question de l'eau des réseaux mais aussi
de la sobriété et du partage de l'eau
pour qu'il y ait une réflexion globale
au niveau de chaque territoire et ça
c'est prévu dans les plans de
souveraineté alimentaire voilà je veux
pas parler trop longtemps parce que je
vais aussi laisser la place au débat
puis aux autres participants donc je
vais m'arrêter là dans un premier temps
je vous remercie
merci Monsieur donc monsieur Suchet je
vous donne la parole
peut-être quelques compléments par
rapport à ce qui vient te dire et ce qui
a été dit aussi par par le président
d'introduction donc je rappelle on le
sait tous que le ministère de la
transition écologique a mis en œuvre une
réforme importante qui est le 0
artificielisation nette qu'on conseille
et qui d'ailleurs fait l'objet d'une PPL
qui a été votée au Sénat qui va être
discuté à partir de la semaine prochaine
à l'Assemblée nationale et qui est une
réforme très structurée en fait et qui a
vocation comme vous le savez de protéger
les espaces naturels et agricoles donc
tous les territoires doit s'engager dans
cette trajectoire pour ce qu'on appelle
le 0 artificialisation nette en 2050
donc ça a beaucoup d'implication et donc
l'un des objectifs je dirais la fin
l'objectif principal c'est effectivement
la protection des espaces naturels et
agricoles donc cette cette réforme
structurante va complètement dans le
sens de nos débats aujourd'hui elle a un
impact aussi par rapport du coup à
l'urbanisation évidemment puisque elle
restreint la capacité géographique ou
physique de d'urbanisation et du coup ça
emporte du point de vue de
l'urbanisation du coup en creux par
rapport à notre débat un changement de
paradigme sur la manière de concevoir la
ville en particulier il faut penser des
formes urbaines plus denses qui
permettent finalement de loger des
activités et des et des habitants sur
des territoires qui évidemment vont être
restreint donc par rapport à ça et pour
revenir sur un point qui a été évoqué
les établissements publics fonciers sont
à la manœuvre pour être des opérateurs
de cette réforme et en particulier de
pouvoir intervenir
maintenant quasiment uniquement
renouvellement urbain l'intervention en
milieu urbain renouvellement urbain
coûte beaucoup plus cher que l'extension
et donc je reviens par rapport en deux
secondes par rapport au débat qu'on a
sur la taxe spéciale d'équipement
le ministère de la transition écologique
n'est à ce stade pas favorable à ce que
la Tsu soit 10 juin en fait de son objet
aujourd'hui qui est le financement des
EPS pour ces raisons que les EPF vont
être amenés à structurer leur activité
sur des opérations qui sont de plus en
plus coûteuses et donc du coup on
s'attend nonobstant l'autre question qui
est prégnante d'une taxation
supplémentaire sur les habitants et les
entreprises qui est un sujet en soi mais
on s'attend à ce que les EPF puissent
donc concourir y compris financièrement
de plus en plus fortement pour
renouveler la ville sur la ville dans
des opérations qui vont être de plus en
plus difficiles
donc voilà donc je voulais je voulais
rajouter ce point là parce que d'une
certaine manière ça contribue aussi à la
préservation des espaces agricoles en
quoi ça c'est le premier deuxième point
vous avez évoqué en Guyane et en Mayotte
l'intervention des epfa donc on est dans
sur deux territoires qui sont
particuliers sur lequel du point de vue
de l'aménagement le gouvernement a fait
le choix contenu des enjeux de mobiliser
un outil qui est un peu
qu'on est exceptionnel des EPA
d'aménagement on en trouve pas partout
sur le territoire français mais
spécifiquement sur ces deux sur des deux
avancés de départements parce qu'il y a
des enjeux d'aménagement qui sont très
forts en particulier à Mayotte avec une
quasi un quasi doublement de la
population envisagée d'ici 2030 2050
donc voilà on est sur des enjeux
extrêmement forts et donc il y a des
missions notamment à Mayotte qui
aujourd'hui sont assurés par les femmes
de sa faire et donc elle intervient pour
les 12 agriculteurs à l'installation des
agriculteurs l'aménagement des parcelles
agricoles et côté Guyane certes il y a
eu effectivement le débat donc vous avez
parlé qui a conduit à la création d'une
saferme il y a une coopération entre les
fags et la SAFER pour justement
travailler de concert sur ces questions
de mise à disposition et de
viabilisation de partielle agricole donc
il y a une convention qui a été signée
avec la fnafer et les fags et il y a un
projet de convention qui est passé au
conseil d'administration des flags de
coopération avec la SAFER locale donc
ces deux établissements interviennent
particulièrement pour constituer des
espaces agricoles dans les surfaces
d'aménagement qui sont aujourd'hui
opérés par ces par ces deux
établissements pour l'aide à la
l'agriculture durable et pour l'aide à
l'installation des jeunes agricoles des
jeunes agriculteurs voilà ce que je
dirais peut-être sur le sur la question
du plan o effectivement ça a été dit
donc je vais pas y revenir mais
effectivement il y a une volonté et des
financements des gens qui sont prévus
pour l'aide à l'agriculture sobre
notamment en matière d'eau pour
le la réflexion et la modernisation des
réseaux d'adduction et d'alimentation en
eau et donc ces aides qui vont être mis
en place viendront évidemment
compléter le dispositif qui a été décrit
sur l'eau donc effectivement il y a un
enjeu très fort qui est très
qui est un enjeu national qui a des
spécificités en outre-mer mais autour du
partage de la ressource et donc on est
sur les territoires
ultramarmain parfois les questions de
ressources sont moins prégnantes que
dans d'autres territoires nationaux je
pense par exemple au sud et au sud-est
et au sud-ouest du territoire
métropolitain en revanche il y a des
questions de pollution qu'il faut qu'il
faut prendre en
œuvre et puis les questions aussi de via
variabilité de la ressource en fonction
de des événements climatiques qu'il faut
aussi prendre en considérant un ration
et qui sont spécifiques
donc là aujourd'hui il y a les stages
qui sont en cours sur les territoires
ultramarins et donc ces stages vont être
renforcés avec cette dimension de
[Musique]
capacité à préserver la ressource
agricole pour pouvoir avoir une
agriculture qui puisse se
conforter et puis aussi qui puisse
également constituer dans le cadre d'une
politique de de
comment dire de de sobriété en fait
pouvoir confronter les équipes
économiques locaux c'est à dire pouvoir
subvenir aux besoins au maximum locaux
aussi donc c'est ces perspectives là qui
sont aussi visées dans le cas de dans le
cadre du Plan haut voilà en ce qui nous
concerne ce que je pouvais en rajouter à
ce stade
très bien merci Monsieur maintenant je
donne la parole au président du conseil
d'administration de l'Office National
des Forêts monsieur collet et Madame
Barbosa merci merci beaucoup mesdames
messieurs merci de nous avoir associés à
cette table ronde effectivement au
préalable je voudrais rappeler le rôle
de l'ONF parce que étant souvent sur le
terrain au contact des habitants qui ont
des projets etc nous sommes ressentis
comme le décisionnaire ce qui n'est pas
notre rôle donc l'ONF gère la forêt
public comme vous le savez et je
voudrais souligner d'emblée que ce rôle
de gestionnaire a un impact sur
l'agriculture
parce que la forêt participe de la
protection des sols en général contre
l'érosion
protège également dans un certain nombre
de cas notamment insulaire de la
remontée saline qui est nuisible à
l'agriculture
constitue également un élément très
important de la ressource en eau
indispensable également à la fois à
l'urbanisme mais aussi à l'agriculture
donc si vous voulez je souhaite qu'on
comprenne bien que le rôle de
gestionnaire de la forêt public n'est
pas un rôle jaloux et égocentrique mais
on le fait parce que l'on connaît les
aménités au regard justement des
activités humaines quelles qu'elles
soient d'une forêt correctement gérée et
protégée alors en ce qui concerne les
questions plus précises que vous nous
avez transmises je voudrais d'abord
souligner que nous n'intervenons que
pour le compte de l'État
pour instruire des demandes ou pour
instruire des procédures c'est-à-dire on
instruit des demandes de défrichement ou
on instruit des procédures contre les
défrichements illicites on les instruit
techniquement
c'est cette mission est financée de
façon spécifique par une mission
d'intérêt général des crédits de mission
intérêt général à hauteur de 1 million
et demi d'euros qui viennent du
ministère de l'Agriculture et de la
souveraineté alimentaire
nous constatons que cette activité
d'instruction se développe même si les
surfaces concernées diminuent ce qui
tente à prouver c'est plutôt une bonne
chose que les gens savent qu'il faut
initier des procédures et demander et
donc font appel à ces procédures au lieu
de se lancer dans le défrichement qui
deviendra illicite et qui on est plutôt
dans une forme de progrès à titre
d'exemple
ce sont 500 visites préalables sur
l'ensemble de l'outre-mer par an qui
sont effectuer pour pré-instruire ou
instruire ce type de demande en ce qui
concerne
ce que vous avez appelé dans votre
questionnaire la taxe donc vous savez
que depuis la lymphe de 2014 il y a
compensation quand il y a des
fraîchements autorisés il n'y a plus de
taxes à proprement parler il y a
compensation soit en reboisement soit en
travail sylvicole pour enrichir
améliorer l'état de la forêt soit quand
ça n'est pas possible effectivement un
versement une compensation pécuniaire
qui n'est ni fixé ni perçu par l'ONF
même si souvent dans l'interface de
dialogue avec nos concitoyens l'agent de
l'office et celui qui les informe en
premier lieu mais cet argent va au fond
stratégique forêt bois
par l'État et le montant de la
compensation pécuniaire quand on ne peut
pas le faire techniquement
est également fixé par l'État même si
évidemment nos services émettent des
propositions par exemple aux Antilles la
compensation pécuniaire quand on ne peut
pas faire autrement est fixé à 1 euro
par mètre carré
avec un coefficient multiplicateur qui
peut aller jusqu'à 5 quand on touche à
des espaces classés ou à des espaces
extrêmement sensibles qu'il est très
difficile de de compenser et il y a
alors c'est peut-être ça qui est
ressenti si vous voulez comme
disproportionné il y a aux Antilles un
minimum forfaitaire de 1000 euros
je pense que cette décision de l'État a
été prise pour dissuader le mitage avec
des tas de petits défrichement qui
finissent par ce maillet et finalement
impacté davantage les surfaces mais
effectivement si vous avez une demande
sur une surface très petite et que on
vous propose le forfait de 1000 euros au
mètre carré ça peut paraître très très
important mais voilà je replace le cadre
c'est effectivement dissuasif dans ce
cas mais l'État a décidé que ceci il en
soit ainsi pour éviter un certain nombre
de multiplication de défrichement
je vais intervenir mais si la personne
défriche pour faire de l'agriculture
elle est sanctionnée quand même elle
elle doit compenser également quand on
change la nature forestière si vous
voulez quel que soit le projet
construction agriculture etc
le principe de la loi de la lave c'est
la compensation vous défricher un
hectare vous devez reconstituer un
hectare enfin en théorie oui mais si
vous êtes chez vous propriétaire de la
friche
on ne parle pas de friche pour l'instant
pas pour l'instant on parle de forêt si
vous voulez le débat sur la friche il
vient tout de suite puisque la question
est de savoir si on est en forêt ou pas
mais si nous sommes en forêt c'est ce
que je viens de décrire qui est le
processus qui s'applique quel que soit
l'activité prévue
si nous sommes dans un enfrichement qui
n'est pas encore forestier et c'est
toute la question là évidemment ça n'est
plus du tout la même chose on remet en
culture un terrain qui était alors il
faut constater que là aussi depuis la
lave de 2014 on a fixé à 30 ans à peu
près
ça correspond à une révolution très
rapide forestière en tout cas au bout de
30 ans on a un espace qui peut être
considéré comme forestier et c'est vrai
que si vous avez laissé votre terrain en
friche pendant plus de 30 ans
vous pouvez difficilement expliquer que
tout d'un coup vous avez un besoin
urgent et vital pour votre exploitation
agricole pour le coup ça redevient à
défrichement maintenant entre temps
il y a possibilité de remettre en
culture
mais moi je constate que aujourd'hui
pour le moment l'ONF n'a pas eu ce genre
de
de demande outre-mer
il y a des raisons d'ailleurs
opérationnelles c'est que un terrain
défricher abandonné outremer très
rapidement il est colonisé par les
espèces notamment invasives sur
lesquelles la question de se pose pas
d'un défrichement puisque en principe on
veut les éliminer donc voyez c'est une
question qui est pertinente parce que il
faut se poser la question des friches
mais elle est pas forcément forestière
et de toute façon suivant la loi il
appartiendrait au propriétaire
deux démontrer qu'il y a moins de 30 ans
à parcelle était agricole pas toujours
évident mais enfin il y a quand même
suffisamment de témoignages de de photos
de choses qui peuvent éventuellement
apporter ça mais pour l'instant nous ne
sommes pas confrontés en tout cas pas de
façon massive à ce type de problématique
ça reste intéressant parce que pour le
coup une friche elle est négative parce
qu'une friche ne se constitue pas en
forêt à protéger pour le futur elle se
constitue en zone de colonies par des
espèces qu'on souhaiterait voir moins
s'implantés donc si vous voulez il y a
pas de doute sur la stratégie que nous
souhaiterions nous techniquement encore
une fois je reprends le rôle technique
de l'ONF qui n'est pas le décideur mais
nous n'avons pas intérêt à avoir des
friches protégées continuer de
proliférer avec des espèces invasives
une belle forêt une belle agriculture
avec un aménagement du territoire bien
pensé et bien équilibré c'est nous
préférons cela effectivement une sorte
de laisser aller donc voilà pour les
pour les premières les premières
questions qui sont effectivement très
importantes vous avez posé la question
de l'échange foncier sur les terrains
qui sont pollués à la chlordécone
notamment alors
je vais tenter de vous donner des
éléments sans donner l'impression de
trop beauté en touche mais pour le
moment
la manière dont la forêt pourrait
participer à la dépollution
pas complètement établi on sait qu'une
espace forestier en tout cas protège
d'autres utilisations du sol qui
pourraient présenter des inconvénients
donc l'idée que la forêt puisse jouer un
rôle dans cette affaire est tout à fait
pertinente maintenant l'échange c'est
une autre affaire parce que ça voudrait
dire qu'on autoriserait des
défrichements
on fera une compensation à l'envers en
quelque sorte et ça pour le moment la
loi ne le prévoit pas
le fait de planter une forêt ne vous
autorise pas à défricher le fait de
défricher vous oblige à replanter ça
marche dans ce sens là mais pour le
moment nous ne pouvons pas vous dire que
ce serait une bonne idée parce que la
loi ne le permet pas
il est assez évident que si on établit
que la forêt accélère la dépollution
ce sera effectivement un sujet à
travailler parce qu'encore une fois on
est sur des territoires limités en
surface et que ce mode de traitement des
surfaces polluées
devra être conçu dès lors qu'il sera
bien établi techniquement qu'il est
performant il faudra se poser la
question
voilà ce que je peux vous dire à ce
stade sur cette question là pour laisser
des penaf
l'ONF outremer n'est pas membre de chez
les penaffes ne participent pas au cdp9
on y est parfois associé avec voie
consultative mais on en est pas membre
donc
quand on nous demande notre avis à titre
consultatif nous le donnons dans
l'esprit de que je vous indiquais au
départ de protection de la forêt parce
qu'elle a des aménités sociales
notamment et environnementales tout à
fait important bien évidemment
je ne porterai pas de d'avis sur le
caractère conforme des avis des cdp-9
outre-mer par rapport à
la loi hexagonale la loi acceptée
le fait que le foncier étant un enjeu
beaucoup plus tendu outre-mer il est
assez logique que les moyens de défense
des terrains agricoles soient un petit
peu plus musclées mais c'est un avis
hors de mes compétences et au vu des
échanges qui ont qui ont eu lieu tout à
l'heure
ensuite pour l'agroforesterie
l'ONF délivre les autorisations et nous
pensons que c'est intéressant à la fois
pour la production pour sa qualité pour
sa reconnaissance aussi de qualité
environnementale c'est intéressant
également parce que ça permet de rompre
un petit peu la frontière entre
agriculture et forêts
vous savez
l'agriculteur voit toujours la forêt
comme une frontière d'un espace
éventuellement à conquérir et Le
Forestier voit l'agriculteur comme une
activité qui va éventuellement grignoter
le territoire forestier dont il a la
charge d'assurer la protection
l'agroforesterie permet de faire
comprendre l'intérêt mutuel des deux
occupations de l'espace et à ce titre là
l'OMF instruit et et je dirais tente de
de favoriser les l'agroforesterie je
laisserai Nathalie peut-être préciser
parce que suivant les territoires les
choses sont très différentes mais
c'est effectivement quelque chose qui
nous paraît tout à fait important par
exemple à Mayotte
ou la déforestation est un problème
majeur qui qui porte ses conséquences
sur l'eau de manière visible et même
comment dire très très
prégnante il est évident qu'il est mieux
d'avoir des agriculteurs protégeant le
couvert forestier parce qu'il l'aurait
bénéfique plutôt que de laisser une
frontière un peu un peu sauvage
s'installer entre des gens qui
défrichent et une forêt qui les périt
donc c'est vraiment un exemple tout à
fait interrompre intéressant de ce point
de vue là alors il y a toujours le
problème de la mise en concurrence c'est
à dire que quand vous donnez
l'autorisation à quelqu'un sur un
territoire public de pratiquer une
activité privée vous lui donnez pour un
certain temps et au bout de ce certain
temps il faut savoir si on le renouvelle
ou s'il y a quelqu'un d'autre qui
demande il faut que nous gérons cette
interface qui est pas toujours simple
parce que les comment dire les
redevances d'occupation sont modestes et
attribuer un lot à quelqu'un au motif
qui donnera trois maravés de plus que
son prédécesseur c'est pas forcément
pertinent d'autant que pour nous ça
n'est pas une ressource financière en
rejoint le problème des valeurs il y a
que nous ce qui nous intéresse c'est que
le travail soit bien fait c'est pas
forcément qu'on touche quelques euros de
plus à l'hectare de culture on
agroforesterie donc ça cette question là
ce gère assez souvent avec du maintien
au gré agréé avec des choses comme ça
mais qui peut pour les installations de
jeunes
apparaître de temps en temps comme une
limite également
nous essayons là dessus avec un cahier
des charges relativement détaillé qui
permet effectivement une qualité
une qualité de
comment dire à la fois forestière et
et agricoles qui est vraiment une
synergie enfin un dernier point que je
voudrais évoquer c'est le projet de
règlement proposé par la Commission
européenne pour lutter contre la
déforestation et la dégradation
forestière
on vous laissera ce enfin vous
connaissez cette directive ce petit
schéma qui l'explicite très bien c'est à
dire que en fait il y a un effet de
cliquer
tout ce qui est en forêt doit rester en
forêt
avec les systèmes de compensation
éventuelle enfin grosso modo la logique
de cette directive c'est ce qui est
forestier reste forestier
ce qui est foret primaire
ne peut pas être transformé en forêt
plantée cultivée etc oui
c'est une espèce de poupée russe
restrictive et
ce qui est foret de plantation ne peut
pas être défricher donc on a vraiment
une directive qui va renforcer encore la
protection des espaces forestiers je
parlais de signaler en conclusion de
cette présentation déjà trop longue et
je vous remercie de votre attention on
vous remettra si vous voulez la petite
note qui détaille un peu certains
chiffres et certains points de vue
territoire par territoire
avec plaisir merci beaucoup peut-être
que Madame barbe vous souhaitez apporter
moi je vais juste apporter peut-être
deux trois éléments de complément sur ce
dernier point de la gros foresterie pour
le fils National des Forêts c'est bien
une production agricole sous couvert
forestier c'est pas
la parcelle forestière on maintient
quelques arbres pour y faire de la
production agricole un CF ce qui se
passe à Mayotte avec des
occupations illégales pour y faire de
l'agriculture au sein de la forêt public
et qui entraîne des conséquences c'est
qu'à terme sur cette île de Mayotte et
pour reboucler avec ce que disait
Jean-Yves collet au début on a tellement
supprimé de la forêt pour y faire de
l'agriculture illégale qu'en fait on se
retrouve avec un problème de
disponibilité en eau sur cette île et
particulièrement en 2023 qui remet
complètement en cause y compris
l'agriculture en zone complètement
légale donc on est pleinement sur si on
repousse le le l'agroforesterie de
l'agriculture deux trois arbres au
milieu nous louerf ça on ne peut pas par
rapport aux missions qu'on a le laisser
faire d'où cette notion de quand on met
des lots susceptibles d'accueillir de
l'agroforesterie on définit bien un
cahier des charges l'état de la forêt au
début de la concession pour
agroforesterie les itinéraires
techniques qui peuvent être mis en place
par l'agriculteur c'est
pas de produits phyto dans quel cas etc
les itinéraires pas de placement de sol
etc et puis chaque année on fait l'objet
d'un contrôle pour bien s'assurer que le
peuplement en place soit bien là à
l'issue de la concession d'occupation
temporaire effectivement le règlement de
lutte contre la déforestation et contre
la dégradation des forêts va entraîner
des conséquences non négligeables pour
les territoires ultramarins parce que
l'objectif de la Commission européenne
et d'imposer à des pays producteurs
producteurs
d'huile de palme de Cannes de boeuf avec
des front pionniers de déforestation
très important
d'imposer à l'Union européenne de
s'appliquer à elle-même ce qu'elle ne
veut pas voir fait par d'autres pays et
donc du coup on s'applique nous Union
européenne et donc comme on a ces
territoires
ultramarins on va devoir appliquer et
comme c'est sur ces territoires qu'on a
beaucoup encore de forêt primaires ça va
avoir des conséquences sur les produits
qui sont
éventés qui sont produits après
déforestation donc ça va redonner de la
force à tout le dispositif qui est mis
en place demande d'autorisation de
défrichement compensation etc
si on reste sur l'agro-forêt théorie
foresterie pour donner un peu des images
puisque le président a bien rappelé que
c'était très différent d'un territoire à
un autre à la Réunion la vanille de
bourbon avec son appellation d'origine à
plus d'antériorité par rapport à des
concessions d'occupation temporaire pour
pour agroforesterie production de
vanille on a aussi des ruchers qui sont
installés en forêt et on voit bien là
que des ruchers en forêt on a aucune
aucune conséquence sur le peuplement
Foresti on comprend pourquoi il y a
cette cette historique en Guadeloupe
c'est une démarche qui est en train de
prendre de l'ampleur avec trois
productions essentiellement vanille
cacao et café donc café cacao sont des
productions qui sont dans le périmètre
du règlement de lutte contre des
forestations et dégradation donc là ça
va avoir des conséquences et en
Martinique c'est un territoire un île
sur lequel ça a démarré plus tardivement
mais sur lequel il y a énormément de
demandes et comme je l'ai expliqué tout
à l'heure pour nous c'est une production
sous couvert forestier ça nécessite pour
le NF d'identifier les parcelles
forestières dont le couvert permet
d'accueillir une activité agricole donc
là on est en train d'identifier les lots
et on va les mettre en concurrence voilà
et effectivement on est tout à fait
conscient que une concession pour une
production par exemple de cacao le plan
de cacao mettant 5 ans pour produire
c'est sûr qu'il s'agit pas de de tout de
suite arrêté le la concession il faut
que l'agriculteur ait un retour sur
investissement de ce qu'il a fait en
même temps on peut pas s'engager au-delà
de 18 ans sauf à avoir après soumettre
ses concessions à l'avis du propriétaire
dont le représentant est ministère
l'agriculture on rentre sur des
processus un peu long
voilà je compléterai si jamais il y a
des questions
merci beaucoup je vais me tourner vers
mes collègues savoir si elles ont des
interrogations notre collègue Victorin
Lurel qui nous a rejoint aussi
je te donne la parole
merci madame la Présidente alors j'ai
deux questions bonjour à tous d'ailleurs
j'ai deux questions une à l'OMF et une
au ministère alors ONF alors depuis
plusieurs auditions nous évoquons ici la
question du foncier en outre-mer et à
mon avis l'accès aux fonciers passe
aussi par la possibilité de profiter de
nos territoires l'utilisation dont
j'aime motorisé sur le domaine forestier
et bien entendu strictement réglementé
mais en Guyane les pistes forestières
permettent aux chasseurs et aux
promeneurs d'accéder à notre territoire
pourtant elles sont strictement
interdites pouvons-nous envisager un
consensus avec l'ONF pour favoriser des
accès réglementés et je pose ma question
ministère l'État est certaines communes
ont accepté d'installer des agriculteurs
le long des pistes forestières
aujourd'hui en raison de la fin de
l'activité forestière ces pistes ne sont
plus entretenues les agriculteurs
éprouvent le plus grand mal à maintenir
leurs activités le rapport d'Olivier
d'un médecin rendu il y a quelques
semaines plaide bien pour une
amélioration des conditions d'exercice
des professions agricoles je connais les
difficultés administratives autour des
anciennes pistes forestières alors
qu'attendez-vous pour lancer un état des
lieux et je rappelle que ces conditions
ont poussé deux agriculteurs à mettre
fin à leurs jours voilà mes deux
questions précédentes
alors sur les pistes en Guyane
donc
en 2022 il y a eu des discussions
d'entamer avec les chasseurs pour
permettre et définir dans quelles
conditions l'accès aux pistes au
chasseur pour moi ce problème il est
résolu donc je sais pas s'il y a un
point particulier mais il y a eu des
échanges pour effectivement prendre en
compte que les chasseurs ils accèdent et
que c'est un tout à l'heure monsieur
martinchar a beaucoup insisté sur la
souveraineté alimentaire de ces
territoires on est bien conscient que la
chasse c'est aussi l'un des leviers pour
atteindre donc sauf à ce qui est un une
piste forestière sur lequel il y a un
problème particulier mais normalement le
travail a été fait poste covid sur ce
plan là après vous avez posé la question
de l'entretien des pistes
en Guyane aussi en Guyane aussi c'était
juste pour être sûr ouais alors Guyane
pour rappeler le contexte en fait bon il
y a deux routes nationales et l'ensemble
de l'infrastructure d'accès à
l'intérieur des 8 millions d'hectares
mais surtout les 6 qu'on gère c'est
effectivement les pistes forestières les
pistes forestières étant le préalable
pour pouvoir aller désigner les bois qui
sont exploités dans cette forêt primaire
donc c'est un préalable l'investissement
au sens de la création des pistes elle
est financée par les fonds féadères
jusqu'au 1er janvier 2023 qui prévoyait
des maquettes là on est en train de
mettre en application le PSN mais si on
regarde dans le rétroviseur financement
à 100% c'est à dire que
on avait de quoi faire la création des
pistes par contre l'entretien et les
deux dernières années avec des
conditions météorologiques très très
compliqué avec beaucoup beaucoup d'eau
en Guyane effectivement la topographie
et la conception de ces pistes fait que
on a des travaux d'entretien qui sont
très importants et ces travaux
d'entretien ne font pas l'objet de
subventions donc en fait c'est le l'ENF
qui doit assurer le financement et donc
son équilibre économique sans modèle
économique doit arriver à des équilibres
entre la piste les kilomètres de pistes
qui nécessitent d'être entretenu et il
nécessite d'être entretenu vu de l'ENF
par rapport à la ressource bois qu'on va
extraire de ces massifs donc
effectivement pour pour être un peu
précis le massif de Balata qui est l'un
des les plus anciens quand on va avoir
une vidange totale de ce qui est permis
par l'aménagement forestier de ce massif
la piste va être fermée au sens de l'OMS
sauf si
la collectivité l'état etc décide de
changer le statut de piste forestière il
y a des discussions qui sont en cours
pour dire il y a deux routes nationales
on a besoin à accéder à l'intérieur de
ce territoire est-ce qu'il faut pas
changer le statut de piste mais tant que
ça reste une piste forestière si on a
plus de grume de bout de bois à aller
exploiter dans ses forêts nous on sera
obligé de fermer la piste voilà et on a
bien conscience des difficultés que ça
pose notamment parce que ces pistes
forestières c'est celle aussi qui donne
accès à l'intérieur du le territoire
pour leur paillage légal par exemple
au-delà des chasseurs etc qui n'abîment
pas les pistes leur paillage c'est aussi
il y a des charges roulantes très
importantes qui contribuent à pour
l'instant c'est le NF qui prend en
charge donc effectivement c'est un sujet
si un sujet qui est sur la table depuis
des années pour l'instant j'ai envie de
dire en plus le sujet parce qu'on n'est
pas encore dans une dans un contexte où
on a plus de vidange de bois à faire
mais plus on avance dans le temps plus
ce sujet va être posé
le président t'apporter un élément en
fait
il y a de nombreux jeunes agriculteurs
qui sont installés justement de part et
d'autre d'épices forestières et comme
vous l'avez dit quand il y a une chez
nous il y a une plus vieux métrique et
particulière et bien ils ont des
véhicules qui sont abîmés parce que
celle-là l'atterrite il y a aucun
entretien et nous justement la
discussion que nous avons eu avec le
préfet c'est de savoir qui qui pouvait
les aider parce que bien souvent mais
ils abandonnent parce que ils n'en
peuvent plus ils sont très très loin de
la nationale alors les enfants sont
scolarisés donc ça veut dire qu'il faut
qu'il la réveille depuis 4h du matin
pour faire la route leur donner le petit
déj sur le bord de la route en attendant
le bus enfin vous voyez je sais pas si
vous imaginez ce que vivent et bien
souvent ils cesse il cesse leur activité
parce que ou alors ils mettent fin à
leurs jours tout simplement voilà on est
convaincus c'est des difficultés aussi
du modèle économique de l'ONF en Guyane
c'est que contrairement à l'Hexagone où
finalement le schéma de dessert il a été
réalisé depuis des années et à l'ONF
dans l'Hexagone le volume de bois mis en
vente chaque année équilibre les charges
aussi parce qu'on est des sur des
climats ou dans l'Hexagone l'entretien
d'une piste elle est pas la même et la
dégradation n'est moindre et les pistes
de l'hexano ne sont utilisés
pratiquement que par l'ONF ou les
usagers au sens loisir on voit bien
qu'en Guyane c'est une problématique
très différente c'est
et entièrement conscient des kilomètres
que ça représente pour les populations
qui vivent sur ces territoires
une petite précision qui vous rassurera
pas Madame mais ce type de problème on
le connaît aussi parfois dans l'Hexagone
dans les zones périurbaines où les
pistes forestières ont fini par
représenter des itinéraires intéressants
de délestage de raccourcis et où l'usage
a augmentant la détérioration augmente
et où l'office considère que c'est pas
lui de d'entretenir des itinéraires
routiers du quotidien pour la population
et quand ça devient dangereux parce
qu'il y a trop d'ornières etc on est
parfois amené dans ces cas là à fermer
la piste à l'usager qui en avait
l'habitude depuis 10 ans depuis 15 ans
tout simplement parce que le modèle que
vient de reciter
Nathalie barbe ne le permet pas non plus
alors c'est des cas plus rares mais si
vous voulez c'est bel et bien une
problématique si une infrastructure doit
être entretenu au titre d'un modèle
économique qui ne le permet pas elle se
dégradera et si on en a besoin et j'ai
cru comprendre que c'était bel et bien
le cas il faut arriver à trouver le
moyen que l'infrastructure en question
rendent l'usage qu'on attendait sinon et
en plus on perd si vous voulez le nom
d'entretien fait perdre une part de
l'investissement même si la dégradation
est rapide en Guyane si en plus on
entretient pas régulièrement c'est
quasiment une réflexion de piste au bout
d'un certain temps qu'il faudra faire et
qui coûtera encore davantage
et sur ce problème des pistes alors bien
sûr le problème est important et bien
identifié on a eu le report de le
rapport de Monsieur de la maison qu'on
vous a communiqué en toute transparence
donc actuellement
le problème a été décrit par Monsieur
collet et Madame barbe c'est en gros qui
doit payer l'entretien des pistes c'est
ça le sujet et dans ces cas-là tout le
monde se tourne vers l'état en disant
mais bon sang mais c'est bien sûr l'État
n'a qu'à payer entretien des pistes et
c'est vrai qu'il y a un je crois que la
discussion avec les mers c'était de dire
écoutez ça coûte cher le premier travail
qui est une véritable réflexion la piste
est très dégradée donc comme ils disent
écoutez on veut bien le faire mais
commencer par la remettre à niveau
qu'ensuite nous on est un travail
d'entretien beaucoup plus léger mais à
partir d'une piste qui ne soit pas une
piste totalement dégradée qu'il faut de
A à Z et encore une fois il y a une
différence aussi entre une piste
publique et une piste qui est privée
parce que c'est pas le même niveau de
sécurité qu'on peut exiger donc c'est
pas le même coup de réflexion donc là on
a un train on a le rapport a été remis
récemment on a initié un travail avec la
préfecture et on doit en parler en
réunion interministe qui a des réunions
terminales régionales maintenant donc il
y en a une pour la Guyane qui est prévue
le 23 juin ce sujet qui n'est pas simple
moi j'ai pas de de solution
préétablies et de clé en main à vous
donner mais en tout cas le sujet est
bien identifié et on en discute avec la
préfecture et bien sûr on associera les
parlementaires sur la façon dont on peut
traiter ce sujet parce qu'effectivement
ça contribue à l'isolement des
agriculteurs non seulement la
dégradation de la piste mais aussi
souvent ils sont installés dans des
zones blanches il y a pas de téléphone
il y a pas d'internet et donc il y a un
sentiment de solitude qui se développe
et on sait d'insécurité et on sait qu'en
ce moment on manque d'eau dans
l'Hexagone mais par contre en Guyane on
a trop d'eau il pleut tout le temps et
donc les mêmes pour faire les travaux
c'est un problème on peut pas faire les
travaux quand il pleut
juste pour donner un ordre de grandeur à
ce que je disais tout à l'heure le NF
crée à peu près 40 km par an Vienne il y
a 400 km de route en Cotonou
le piste forestier
merci pour ces explications moi je
voudrais avant de terminer quand même
poser quelques questions concernant un
désordre fine foncier il y a eu un
rapport récent décembre 2022 qui a
pointé donc ce désordre foncier sur
l'ampleur des divisions par exemple en
Martinique près de 40% de fonciers se
trouvent perturbé par par l'indivision
les problèmes les problématiques liées
au titrement du passé parce que bon ben
on s'est rendu compte qu'il y avait
quand même quelques propriétaires
c'est-à-dire pour ça qu'il leur cède pas
leur parcelle parce qu'en fait ils n'en
sont pas propriétaire officiellement
soit qu'il n'est jamais passé un acte où
il n'y a pas de cadastre enfin c'est
quand même sa porte quand même grande
complications le manque de
professionnels dans ce domaine
d'ailleurs justement tout à l'heure nous
évoquait les notaires mais il semblerait
que leur présence et leur disponibilité
sur ces l'histoire est vraiment limitée
et donc il ne peut pas faire tout ce
qu'ils ont il y a aussi un nombre
considérable de construction sans permis
et un manque de police pour sanctionner
justement ce manque de police à
l'urbanisme la multiplication
d'occupation illégale effectivement tout
à l'heure où nous évoquez le fermage
mais il semblerait que certaines ne
veulent pas du tout à l'intérieur de
parler parce qu'au bout d'un certain
temps la personne qui fait qui occupe le
terrain ne paye plus de loyer en disant
mais non c'est moi qui l'entretien je
suis chez moi et il y a plus moyen donc
ça ça pose quand même quelques
difficultés et puis il y a bien
évidemment les imperfections du cadastre
où je reviens bon toutes ces personnes
qui étaient
qui ne sont pas vraiment même si elles y
sont depuis
un passé lointain
ça n'a jamais été signifié et donc ça ça
pose quand même un problème on a cru
comprendre qu'un Martinique c'était
peut-être 12000 ça représente pas une
quantité mais enfin 12000 personnes
voilà donc j'aurais aimé savoir ce que
vous pensez
quel bilan voudrait essayer de la loi
les chimie et qu'est-ce que l'homme sur
quel point précis on pourrait la
perfectionner pour réduire donc
l'indivision successoriale et puis deux
autres petits points sur lequel on avait
peut-être pas où je n'ai pas bien
compris le prochain projet de loi
d'orientation et d'avenir agricole
est-ce qu'il comportera un volet
outre-mer et dans l'affirmative sur quel
point particulier
et puis une question qui je tiens je
sais qui est à cœur à mon collègue Tani
Mohamed sali puisqu'à chaque fois il la
pose est-ce que pour faciliter les
transmissions d'exploitation un
dispositif de fond agricole comme les
fonds de commerce existe-t-il ou
pourrait-il être pertinent je vous
remercie
merci alors sur le sur le titrement bien
sûr on sait que la nature ayant horreur
du vide à chaque fois qu'on comprend
trop de temps que les commissions
d'attribution foncières prennent trop de
temps et bien des gens s'installent de
manière illégale on le sait très bien
c'est surtout vrai d'ailleurs en Guyane
où on disait à l'époque je sais pas si
c'est toujours vrai mais d'où était basé
cette affirmation tous les jours il y a
trois logements qui se construisent un
légal et deux illégaux bon c'est ce
qu'on disait je sais pas si c'est vrai
sur quoi mais on sait en ce qui concerne
le foncier agricole et les agriculteurs
s'en plaignent que la la procédure étant
trop longue quand elle finit par aboutir
quand le la personne arrive sur le
foncier ben il est pas tout seul et que
donc après effectivement il faut de
procédure de police pour aller sortir
des gens qui exploitent des fois depuis
plusieurs années et c'est compliqué mais
je crois que
je sais pas si Monsieur lur toujours là
mais il l'avait rappelé lors du débat
que vous avez eu avec les sénateurs
c'est qu'il y a eu un travail de fait
pour amender la loi les chimie et que il
y a des dispositions qui sont déjà
rédigées pour améliorer cette loi à
partir d'un bilan qui a été fait
important les modifications législatives
à ce à ce travail à partir du moment où
il y a des dispositions agricoles
parlementaire peuvent les porter dans
les discussions sur le projet je vois
l'orientation et d'avenir
sur le ce ploa est-ce qu'il y aura un
volet outre-mer
aujourd'hui le la structure du projet de
loi n'est pas rédigée la démarche
nationale qui a été faite c'est
d'initier des conservations comme je
vous l'ai dit un propos liminaire donc
on a reçu ces contributions d'outre-mer
à la fois des contributions
issues déconcertations que les préfets
ont fait
chaque territoire a fait cette au moins
une concertation publique plus
déconcertations
avec les acteurs et de plus on a reçu
une contribution de chambre
d'agriculture France qui a synthétisé
les retours des chambres de
l'agriculture outre-mer
donc sur tous les sujets il y a des
demandes alors quand on compare à ce que
demande
l'Hexagone c'est souvent un peu les
mêmes sujets il y a pas de on a quelques
sujets spécifiques on a des gens qui
nous demandent de faire de
l'enseignement shimaoré il y a des
demandes sur les pistes agricoles en
Guyane donc ce sont des choses qu'on n'a
pas qui sont spécifiques aux outre-mer
et on pourrait avoir aussi des selon
j'aime parler l'amendement de la loi
l'alchimie ça pourrait des dispositions
d'outre-mer et pour l'instant on en est
à compiler ces demandes et elles ont été
reçues de partout et donc des Outre-mer
mais est-ce qu'il y aura un volet
outre-mer c'est pas encore décidé c'est
pas encore décidé parce qu'il faut qu'il
y ait de la matière qui est suffisamment
de de dispositions spécifiques aux
outre-mer faut que ça constitue un titre
on avait fait un titre outremer
lorsqu'il y avait eu la loi d'avenir de
l'agriculture en 2014 c'est là on avait
mis en place les causes d'art mais voilà
parce que un vol outre-mer c'est pas non
plus obligatoire on peut très bien
insérer des articles
particulier sur l'outre-mer dans un
projet de loi sans pour autant que ça
constitue un titre ça changera rien
c'est juste une histoire d'écriture mais
pour l'instant on n'a pas encore pris la
décision voilà le gouvernement n'a pas
encore pris la décision quant au fond
agricole comme le font de commerce et ça
existe aujourd'hui il faut agricole il
est créé depuis des années et c'est dans
le but de faciliter les transmissions
alors j'ai pas le bilan j'ai pas le
bilan
de son utilisation il existe dans
l'Hexagone comme outre-mer donc oui ça
existe mais je peux pas vous dire
malheureusement parce qu'on n'a pas de
disposition simple
et aisément mobilisable qui nous permet
de d'avoir un bilan de cet utilisation
parce que là aussi après c'est des
procédures qui sont mises en place par
les notaires c'est-à-dire que lors de la
transmission et bien le l'agriculteur
dit mais je transmets mon fond agricole
qui est constitué d'un ensemble foncier
il y a mes équipements il y a mes
bâtiments et je transmets tout ça mais
c'est de même les je pense qu'il y a pas
de mécanisme qui permet au notaire de
transmettre sur tant de transaction et
bien tel nombre c'est fait sur la base
du fond agricole donc on a pas ce bilan
donc c'est vrai que c'est un peu dommage
d'avoir une disposition qui existe donc
on peut pas savoir s'il y a l'efficace
ou pas parce qu'on n'a pas de bilan on
pourrait peut-être y travailler mais
aujourd'hui le mécanisme de collecte des
données qui nous permettrait d'avoir ce
bilan il n'existe pas malheureusement
je constate qu'il y a de nombreuses
choses mais que peut-être c'est pas mis
en place c'est ce qui donne un délai
comme vous le disiez tout à l'heure que
c'est beaucoup trop lent pour les
installations illégales tout ça alors
qu'il existe je crois des solutions mais
qui ne sont pas mises en oeuvre c'est
comme pour par exemple mais les
professionnels dans le domaine les
notaires tout ça sont trop peu nombreux
et ils ne peuvent pas finalement donc
peut-être faudrait-il booster un peu
tout cela si je puis me permettre pour
arriver à des solutions qui sont pas
peut-être pas si compliqué que cela en
fait ils sont moi je crois assez simple
comme le titre le titre m'a je pense
qu'il y a des choses qui pourraient être
faites en tout cas je vous remercie
infiniment
pour toutes les informations que vous
avez pu nous donner sachez que nous
sommes preneurs de tout ce que vous
pourrez nous communiquer par écrit nous
sommes preneurs de tout et voilà je ne
sais pas si monsieur le Président
souhaiterait rajouter quelque chose je
te passe la parole
non merci merci sur Vivette d'avoir
animé cette table ronde à distance et
merci pour vos contributions respectives
vous le savez la tradition c'est de vous
adresser une trame d'audition via un
questionnaire vous êtes habitué
notamment je pense à la armoire
Tranchard qui est qui n'est pas son
premier coup d'essai à la délégation et
donc merci de nous faire parvenir dès
que vous le pourrez évidemment vous
contributions écrites qui vont permettre
d'aider les deux rapporteurs justement
dans la rédaction du rapport et les
préconisations donc merci en tout cas de
vous contribution fort apprécié et merci
Yvette
monsieur le Président et je crois qu'il
y a Micheline qui voulait poser aussi
une question elle ne s'est pas
manifestée avant toi donc je vais passer
la parole je te remercie je suis
vraiment navrée président
au fil des débats j'ai eu le sentiment
puisque ça Barthélémy Noël n'intervient
pas nous avons la compétence en matière
maîtrise gestion du territoire mais j'ai
le sentiment que qu'il n'y a pas de de
concertation enfin peut-être que vous
allez me corriger entre les élus qui
sont en charge aussi de l'aménagement du
territoire et l'ONF donc j'aurais aimé
savoir quelle est la nature des
relations que vous entretenez avec
les exécutifs locaux
alors au niveau national déjà nous avons
instauré depuis quelques années
seulement une commission consultative de
des forêts d'outre-mer ce qui nous
permet déjà au niveau central
d'institutions d'institutionnaliser un
dialogue qui n'existait pas donc déjà
c'est une première chose ensuite au
niveau local je vais laisser la parole à
Nathalie pour vous expliquer comment
dans la pratique les contacts
s'établissent la petite difficulté que
je soulignais un peu au départ si vous
voulez c'est que le pétitionnaire qui
souhaite faire quelque chose
la personne qui va rencontrer quasiment
en premier c'est un agent de l'Office
des forêts et il en va donc considérer
que
la réponse qui lui est donnée elle vient
de cette organisme elle est
exclusivement détenue par cette
organisme et quand ça ne lui convient
pas il va aller solliciter
éventuellement un élu en disant mais
l'ONF me refuse mon projet et l'élu à ce
moment-là n'est absolument pas au
courant de ce projet de détail et
légitimement peut dire mais moi on m'a
parlé de rien je découvre ça après donc
voilà maintenant Nathalie peut-être des
précisions sur l'institutionnalisation
du dialogue local et au fil des
procédures
alors je vais le prendre dans le sens
collectivité territoriale au sens
c'était j'ai ou CTM et puis après je
reviendrai avec l'élu qui peut être sur
la zone sur lequel il y a une forêt de
maniale ou une forêt départementale ou
de Manial territoriale de maniable au
niveau des exécutifs l' ONF a signé et
renouvelle des conventions avec les
conseils départementaux qui sont
propriétaires du propriétaire notamment
à la Réunion notamment à Mayotte il y a
deux jours on vient de renouveler la
convention pluriannuelle cadre avec le
conseil départemental de la Réunion et
j'étais en déplacement au mois de mars
pour signer une convention à être le
conseil départemental de Mayotte
en Martinique on vient aussi de signer
une convention
pluriannuelle là au mois de au mois de
mars ou au mois de février
en Guadeloupe il y en a pas parce que on
est sur un relais qui est peut-être plus
compliqué encore entre le Conseil
Régional et le Conseil départemental il
y a pas de collectivité unique et avec
le la CTG on a des échanges mais pour
l'instant on n'est pas dans une phase de
convention la Guyane était entrée
particulière et que du foncier de Manial
bon c'est on est en train d'y travailler
mais ça c'est pour l'instant c'est on
n'est pas dessus ensuite si maintenant
on
revient au niveau local je suis maire
d'une commune sur lequel il y a du
foncier de Manial ou départementale ou
territorialo de Manial nous à l'ONF la
façon dont on déroule l'aménagement
d'une forêt public on a une phase de de
conception d'un aménagement forestier
sur lequel on va être sur 15 20 ans à
dérouler
quels sont les coupes qu'on va faire
est-ce qu'on va équiper la forêt soit de
route de pistes soit d'infrastructures
d'accueil du public et puis après est-ce
qu'il va y avoir des travaux
sylvicole fait pour essayer de
d'améliorer ce peuplement ou de
l'entretenir cette aménagement forestier
ce document programmatique sur 15 ans il
fait l'objet de concertations avec avec
les j'ai envie de dire les non pas les
propriétaires mais la commune de
situations sur laquelle la forêt public
qui est d'un autre propriétaire est
situé voilà alors après le tout ça c'est
j'ai envie de dire cadrer si vous sur
vos territoires vous avez l'impression
que cette phase de concertation elle
elle doit être améliorée etc n'hésitez
pas c'est l'un des points
l'état signe avec l'ONF un contrat sur
cinq ans c'est l'un des axes
d'amélioration la concertation avec les
communes de situations si elles sont pas
propriétaires donc n'hésitez pas après
c'est pas la même chose de faire de la
concertation sur des massifs comme en
Guyane ou l'ONF gère 6 millions
d'hectares sur les 6 millions d'hectares
gérés il y en a deux millions quatre qui
sont dans le domaine permanent forestier
qui eux font vraiment l'objet d'un
aménagement dans le temps ou en Guyane
les deux millions quatre ils sont
divisés en 35 massifs forestiers chacun
faisant 60 000 hectares ça n'a rien à
voir en terme d'échelle par rapport à
l'Hexagone où on a à peu près 1300
forêts domaniales qui au total font un
million quatre d'hectares donc voyez il
y a aussi l'échelle de la Guyane qui
fait que cette concept concertation
aussi avec des populations très
dispersées la concertation elle est
peut-être plus compliquée à organiser au
21e siècle mais peut-être que les outils
modernes
une précision si vous voulez bien c'est
que vous voyez Nathalie vous expose on
fait une concertation pour l'aménagement
forestier pour 15 ans
ce qui peut laisser entendre que pendant
les 15 années qui suivent on met en
œuvre et on considère que tout le monde
est au courant
c'est pas toujours le cas la durée des
mandals locaux n'est pas de 15 ans ne
cale pas forcément avec les aménagements
forestiers et il peut y avoir par moment
le sentiment de découverte de tel ou tel
axe de tous les tel action bon c'est si
vous voulez la concertation c'est un
sujet en construction permanente il faut
veiller à ce que les outils comment dire
structurant fasse bien l'objet de
concertation mais on ne peut pas
forcément s'en satisfaire parce qu'après
il y a au quotidien
un rapport qui doit vous citer le cas de
quelqu'un qui a un projet qui s'adresse
directement non pas à la DAF mais à
l'ONF on lui donne pas satisfaction et
c'est à ce moment-là que l'élu apprend
qu'il y a un projet alors que peut-être
il l'aurait su dès le départ il lui
aurait dit ton projet tu y arriveras pas
parce que c'est dans ce coin là
et ça crée des situations de tension et
l'élu que j'ai été pendant de nombreuses
années se trouve un petit peu en
situation de porte-à-faux par rapport à
son admin istré qui vient lui poser un
problème dont il aurait aimé être au
courant dedans avant ça aurait évité les
problèmes donc il y a toujours des
progrès à faire je vous citer le progrès
qu'on a fait au niveau national
et donc au niveau local il y a une
concertation j'ai jamais suffisant toute
façon il faut une relation presque
naturelle et permanente nos effectifs
présents sur le terrain sont aussi je le
dis très sollicité voilà ils sont très
sollicités par des enjeux très divers
et voilà mais ils sont quand même
à disposition des élus pour discuter des
sujets
dans les communes où il existe justement
vous êtes présents est-ce que vous êtes
associé au plan locaux d'urbanisme et
autres chez Madame aménagement du
terrain alors en fait juste pour
compléter je reviens sur la mission P8
et Concertation
ce que soulève Jean-Yves collet
en fait si vous êtes une commune
propriétaire ou une collectivité
propriétaire chaque année l'ONF son plan
de gestion avant de le mettre en oeuvre
il revient auprès de l'exécutif soit de
la commune soit du de la collectivité
pour dire l'aménagement il avait prévu
de faire a on revient vers vous pour
dire 2023 est-ce qu'on fait a quel est
votre décision si vous êtes propriétaire
on revient vers vous c'est vous qui
décidez nous on conseille on met en
oeuvre le document que le conseil
municipal précédent a voté a décidé par
contre effectivement la question que
vous posez c'est si je suis une commune
de situations donc c'est sur mon
territoire sur le banc de ma commune qui
est votre forêt de la collectivité ou de
l'État et je déroule c'est là où la
concertation effectivement elle fait pas
partie d'une coche annuelle bon de plus
en plus le dialecte forest société fait
qu'effectivement le maillage le maillage
territorial de de l'ONF fait que on va
au contact et on essaie de d'informer
après est-ce que
la commune elle est
disponible au moment où la décision doit
se prendre etc c'est ça qu'il faut qu'on
arrive à améliorer sur les pays
en fait dans le cadre de l'action une de
la mission d'intérêt général que nous
confie l'État sur le en outre-mer on a
effectivement cette action qui est de
d'assister les directions
départementales de l'agriculture etc des
territoires outre-mer donc en fait le
rôle de l'ONF s'il y a pays lui sur les
zones N qui nous concernent
particulièrement par rapport à nos
missions cœur de métier on est sollicité
et on émet un avis on évalue la
pertinence de l'évolution du zonage de
ce qui est prévu etc on apporte notre
vision d'experts par rapport aux enjeux
mais après la décision
on apporte juste un
œil avec notre expertise
et on donne un avis d'expertise qui
ensuite intégré dans la procédure par le
service de l'État ou pas ou pas
madame merci messieurs voilà je vous le
redis on est sur vous pour vos
contributions écrites voilà merci chers
collègues merci monsieur le Président et
je vous souhaite à toutes et tous une
excellente journée merci et salutations
à Stéphane Artano
merci merci